انظار العالم كله محبي كره القدم تحديدا
متجها الى الرياض التي تنطلق فيها
المواجهه المنتظر بين نجوم الهلال والنصر
ضد باريس سان جيرمان على كاس موسم الرياض
وطبعا المباراه هذه مو المباراه عاديه
فغير انه نجوم الهلال والنصر مجتمعين في
فريق واحد هذه مواجهه بين افضل لاعبين في
العالم ميسي ورونالدو ومباراه بتجمع اهم
نجوم اللعبه في العالم وكان اعلن رئيس
هيئه الترفيه المستشار تركي ال الشيخ عن
وصول طلبات التذاكر لمليونين طلب بعض
طرحها هذه غير تذكره فوق الخيال بمميزات
خياليه واللي عمل عليها مزاد وصل لعشره
مليون ريال وهيروح رايح لصالح منصه احسان
الخيريه الاجواء حماسيه والاعصاب مشدوده
صراحه النجوم الرياضيين اليوم مجتمعين في
الرياض على استاد الملك فهد الدولي هذا
غير انها اول مباراه كمان اللي رونالدو في
السعوديه
ومن ساعات الصباح بدا بث خاص بكاس موسم
الرياض على شاهد وعلي تابع الجميع كمان
وصول فريق باريس سان جيرمان الى الرياض
اللي كان في استقبالهم المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ
[موسيقى]
وكان معالي المستشار التقى امس نجوم
الهلال والنصر او فريق موسم الرياض ووجه
لهم كلمات
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله انا اتمنى ان بكره تاخذ
المباراه بجديه وانا كاس يبقى في الرياض
يلا شكرا شكرا
[موسيقى]
هو بمناسبه الحديث على الموسم الرياض في
امس اعلن معالي المستشار تركي ال الشيخ عن
رقم قياسي مليوني جديد حققوا الموسم بوصول
عدد دائري الى 12 مليون زائر والفعاليات
مكمله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]